how do you know if you're an introvert
like how do you empirically start to
determine
if you are in large part an introvert
well
i would start by just asking that
question of what happens to you um you
know at around the two hour mark where
you're having a good time yeah like i
mean imagine every day but but i also
find i'm curious if you have a different
experience from this but from all the
years that i've been out there talking
about this topic i found that
most people really seem to know
once they're being honest with
themselves and maybe that's the question
to ask is like if you imagine that you
have
a saturday or a whole weekend where you
can spend your time exactly the way you
want to with no professional obligations
and no social obligations
who would you spend it with how many
people what would you be doing
and and what is that picture that you're
painting start to look like
yeah so there's nuance to this though
because um i'm sure for extroverts to
get energized by
stimulation whether that stimulation
with other people like it depends what
that stimulation is right
like maybe you're not surrounded by the
kind of people that you enjoy being
around
so you know
um
maybe that has to do less with whether
some characteristics is your personality
more has to do with the fact what like
what your environment is like that's
always kind of
uh the question do you want to be alone
because everybody around you is an
[ __ ] or do you want to be alone
because you get energized from being
well i would hold the variables constant
i guess i would say
you know
keep the [ __ ] constant and see
and then there's the other thing you
kind of observe that there's a lot of
people
that will say they get energized from
being alone
like
people are exhausting to them or
something like that but at the same time
when you see them at a party they seem
like the life of the party
i know and i hear from those people all
the time there are so many people like
what would you classify them as exactly
is it ultimately as the source of energy
is the most important thing or like how
the heck are they the life of the party
it's a bunch of different things you
know so first of all just to say like a
big
caveat to all of this is humans are just
amazingly complex so you can't like
explain every individual humans through
these parameters even though i think the
parameters are really valuable but that
person at the party it could be
that they're more of an ambivert so they
kind of are more in the middle of the
spectrum that's it basically means
someone who's not extremely introverted
or extremely extroverted they're kind of
in the middle so maybe at a party their
more extroverted side comes out
um or it could be
an introvert who's gotten really good at
the skills of acting more like a
pseudo-extrovert and they pull that up
at the moment that they need it
so they've learned how to fake it yeah
oh there's a lot of people like that and
i know this because like i think out of
all the people on this planet you could
be talking to i've heard from the most
number of those people like they all
come and tell me about their experience
out in the world presenting a face
that's different from what they feel so
one of the things you talk about is
at least in the west we've constructed a
picture of success and that picture
is usually one
of an extrovert like when you imagine
somebody who's a leader who's a
successful person
that person has some of the qualities
you would associate with an extrovert
and so
there's a lot of incentive
for uh faking it
yeah exactly if you if you want to be
successful you got to be able to to fake
it to sort of uh
hang with the rest of the team you have
to you have to be able to be outgoing
and all those kinds of things and not be
drained by the interaction
yeah but i mean there are also a lot of
introverts who figure out ways to draw
on their own strengths and they're
incredibly
connecting and successful and they're
great leaders and they're not actually
faking it they're more just figuring out
ways to do it their own way
you see a lot of people like that
you